represent how some intolerant people
have labeled
minorities here we see a black person
eating Chicken and watermelon a
stereotype that hurts the
African-American Community what other
stereotypes do you see here oh here's
that everyone loves chicken and what
that's right but of course we know that
not all Arabs are terrorists don't we
kids well there's an Asian man with a
calculator that's right not all
stereotypes are negative but even a
positive one like all Asians are good at
math is harmful to society look a
Covetous Jew very good young man the
idea that Jews are only interested in
money is very old indeed ah here's a
good one it's the stereotypical sleepy
Mexican whoa what oh man what time is it
oh I'm sorry I thought you were a wack
sculpture no man I'm the janitor I'm
supposed to be cleaning but I'm so tired
I don't understand bust their ass